merci monsieur le ministre
d'abord il faut effectivement revenir au
contenu de l'amendement parce que c'est
bien de faire des grandes déclarations
de parler de tout mais en réalité on
parle de rien et il s'agit d'amendement
il s'agit d'amendement qui
la parole
est un jour merci
député de la France insoumise
je vous dis vos amendements ne savent
rien parce que Monsieur Tavel qu'est-ce
que vous voulez vous voulez quoi vous
voulez recommencer vous voulez ma tête
comme votre collègue c'est ça que vous
voulez vous voulez continuer dans la
violence vous voulez continuer dans la
stigmatisation vous aussi vous voulez
poser avec ma tête coupée
pose d'amendements sont inutiles c'est
de l'obstruction et votre comportement
ne sert à rien
amendement suivant le 20 286
monsieur porte
madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres
calmez-vous collègues il y a pas de
ballons ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
soyez pas étonné mon cher collègue soyez
pas étonné
je suis très intense
allez
allez un peu de silence s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
un petit silence
s'il vous plaît
un peu de silence allez-y exprimez-vous
merci madame la Présidente
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez mes chers collègues
allez s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît un peu de silence
allez-y
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur porte je crois que l'hémicycle
vous demande des excuses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie madame panot pour un
rappel au règlement
[Applaudissements]
allez on écoute la présidente panneau
madame la Présidente je vous demande une
suspension de séance et je ne suis pas
d'accord avec l'impartialité donc vous
avez fait preuve
[Applaudissements]
alors
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors tout le monde a pu regagner sa
place donc nous allons reprendre la
défense de l'amendement 20286 monsieur
porte vous avez la parole
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà
Monsieur Blanchet pour un rappel au
règlement
merci Madame la prison au titre de
l'article 70 alinéa 1 2 et 5
qui c'est un notamment le 5 qui se livre
coupable d'ingures de provocation de
menaces envers le président de la
République le Premier ministre les
membres du gouvernement ou les
assemblées prévues par Constitution
madame la
madame la Présidente hier un collègue de
la majorité a présenté ses excuses aux
collègues Louis Boyard qui les a
acceptés et à retiré son tweet et la
scène s'est arrêtée là en chers
collègues nous vous demandons de
présenter vos excuses pour rester là et
pouvoir continuer les débats
et retirer le tweet évidemment
je vous remercie
je vous remercie monsieur porte
merci madame la Présidente
[Applaudissements]
je vais je vais ici défendre notre
abonnement de suppression
[Applaudissements]
madame Aurore berger la présidente pour
un rappel aux règlements merci madame la
Présidente sur le fondement aussi de
l'article 70-5 nous ne laisserons passer
aucun comportement qui dégrade notre
Assemblée nationale aucun comportement
nous exigeons des excuses de votre part
pour les propos que vous avez eu
l'attitude provocatrice qui est la vôtre
nous ne laisserons rien passer jamais
comment il s'appelle
alors Monsieur Thirion Arabel au
règlement rappelle au Règlement sur le
fondement de l'article 70 pour la
sérénité de nos débats nous devons
savoir que dans cette émission ceux qui
comptent c'est la délibération
démocratique c'est l'échange des idées
c'est le respect de l'autre
lorsque publiquement on affiche sur les
réseaux sociaux une tête en effigie
foulée au pied la tête du président de
la République qui n'est pas notre
majorité mais peu importe c'est un acte
qui porte atteinte à la République une
violence en effigie demeure une violence
nous ne sommes pas du côté des coupeurs
de tête nous sommes du côté de ceux qui
respectent le débat
je vous remercie madame Garrido pour un
rappel au règlement
[Applaudissements]
sur le fondement de l'article 45 de la
Constitution
qui fait partie intégrante de notre
règlement intérieur chers collègues
c'est la deuxième partie vous pouvez le
consulter si vous voulez et alors c'est
un ici qui m'explique la Constitution
s'applique pas à nous bonjour la
conception que vous avez de notre
règlement
l'article collègue écoutez un peu
écoutez un petit peu
l'article 45 de la Constitution donne à
chacun d'entre nous en droit à
l'amendement qui est en droit individuel
et inaliénable ce que vous êtes en train
de faire à l'instant sur le fondement
d'un désaccord politique qui a sa
légitimité
vous avez le droit d'être en
vous avez le droit d'être en désaccord
politique vous avez le droit d'avoir une
opinion politique sur l'expression de
nos de vos collègues à l'extérieur comme
à l'intérieur mais vous n'avez pas le
droit d'entraver le droit d'amendement
des députés vous êtes en train de
d'entraver les travaux de l'Assemblée
nationale vous êtes en train de faire
une obstruction celle dont vous accusez
en permanence les autres vous êtes en
train de violer la constitution si vous
avez des comptes politiques à régler
avec monsieur porte si vous avez
absolument la défense à faire de
Monsieur du soft qui d'ailleurs est un
grand garçon on peut aussi le faire
lui-même vous n'avez pas le droit
d'empêcher un député de présenter un
amendement c'est la Constitution qui
doit s'appliquer nous avons eu une
conversation tous ensemble au pied de la
tribune avec madame la Présidente un peu
de silence il a été convenu
collègue vos protestations vos
protestations
ridicule comme vous l'a dit mon collègue
Ruffin vous faites pitié vous faites
pitié vous ne supportez pas la
conversation
[Applaudissements]
réglez vos problèmes politiques là où
il doit aller dans l'émission
Qui veut compter l'expression et
la legue pour un rappel au règlement
monsieur Mornet merci madame la
Présidente les choses ont été dites et
bien dites par mon collègue Christophe
Blanchet la présidente berger chers
collègues sincèrement retirer un tweet
article 70
retire présenter ses excuses et retirer
un tweet c'est pas un acte de faiblesse
c'est un acte au contraire qui vous
grandirez voyez bien que les débats là
sont un moment de blocage pour la
sérénité du débat pour la reprise de nos
débats vous comprenez que vous pourrons
pas laisser passer un tweet saint de
l'écharpe tricolore foulant au pied le
président de la République et le
ministre du Travail nous sommes choqués
vous êtes un député de la République
vous n'êtes pas une activiste damphi
présentez vos excuses retirez le tweet
et on passe à autre chose merci je vous
[Musique]
la parole est au président Marc Angeli
pour un rappel au règlement merci sur le
fondement de l'article 70 mon cher
collègue je respecte vos convictions
elles sont respectables mais vous devez
retirer ce tweet c'est obligé vous ne
pouvez pas poser avec votre écharpe vous
ne pouvez pas vous ne pouvez pas faire
ça vous ne pouvez pas faire ça pour la
solennité des débats dans cette maison
vous ne pouvez pas faire ça pour les
idées que vous défendez vous n'avez pas
conscience de la violence de cette image
et c'est grave
soyez humain soyez responsable soyez
démocrate retirez votre tweet
je vous remercie
[Musique]
alors
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que
[Musique]
merci madame la Présidente je vais
essayer de défendre mon amendement si
vous le voulez bien
[Applaudissements]
allez
je suis pas la séance pour une durée de
10 minutes
monsieur vert pour un rappel au
règlement
[Applaudissements]
vous voulez dire quelque chose par
rapport à votre amendement ou non
allez-y allez-y alors
vous retirez cette réforme qui va
sacrifier des milliers
la parole
la parole est à Monsieur le testeur vert
pour un rappel au règlement
rappelle au règlement au titre de
l'article 70 vous exposez monsieur le
député vous exposez un sourire aux
lèvres avec votre écharpe tricolore
foulant des pieds écrasant de vos pieds
la tête d'un ministre de la République
c'est un ni plus ni moi un appel au
meurtre ni plus ni moins un appel au
meurtre imaginez
[Musique]
imaginez un instant
imaginé un instant qu'un député
renaissant imaginé
imaginez un instant qu'un député
Renaissance écrase de son pied et la
tête de Monsieur Mélenchon et je suis
bien certain de votre réaction alors
à leur excusez-vous retirez votre tweet
ou quitter l'hémicycle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour un rappel au règlement
chers collègues
c'est avec
c'est avec le plus profond respect pour
votre élection et pour votre
responsabilité que je m'adresse à vous
le propre d'un état de droit et la
grandeur de notre mission c'est que un
acte peut être inacceptable une parole
peut être inacceptable mais une personne
ne l'est jamais vous pouvez détester ce
que nous disons vous pouvez détester ce
que nous voulons faire et ce que nous
faisons mais nous ne sommes pas
détestables ni nous ni les membres du
gouvernement notre grandeur
c'est de séparer les personnes de leurs
intentions et des idées qu'elles
défendent
aucun nom propre ne mérite d'être sali
aucun visage même symboliquement ne
mérite d'être foulée au pied
si vous ne pouvez pas reconnaître ces
valeurs fondamentales nous ne pouvons
pas délibérer
je vous remercie la parole est à madame
la Présidente panneau pour un rappel au
règlement
[Musique]
on laisse parler madame la Présidente
panot merci madame la présidente madame
la Présidente une première chose vous
m'avez dit tout à l'heure que si Thomas
porte ne retirait pas son tweet nous
irions à la sanction et je vous demande
que enfin nous allions au fait que vous
alliez convoquer le bureau pour qu'on
puisse continuer sur le texte de la
réforme des retraites qui va
dans leur vie quotidienne et dans leur
dernière année de carrière faire mal
attendre millions de Français
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est que oui il y a de la violence dans
la société et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le fait d'utiliser l'image s'il vous
plaît
on écoute la présidente s'il vous plaît
l'image des puissants dans des choses de
folklore comme par exemple dans des
chamboule-tout a toujours mis la
violence à distance cela fait partie de
l'histoire sociale de notre pays
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît lorsqu'on manifestation
ce ne sont des appels au meurtres et
nous nous avons toujours été dans le
camp de celles et ceux qui voulant la
révolution citoyenne par les urnes sans
jamais aucune violence
on est hors voilà donc je vous indique
contenu de ce qui est en train de se
passer dans l'hémistique de l'absence
d'excuse de monsieur porte qui provoque
manifestement un tumulte dans cette
assemblée je convoque un bureau
immédiatement et donc nous nous
retrouvons
et monsieur porte donc vous allez être
vous y êtes convoqué également pour y
être entendu nous adressons une
convocation dans les méduses qui suivent
merci et la séance est suspendue
[Applaudissements]
à la suite des différents
incidents de cet après-midi j'ai
convoqué le bureau de l'Assemblée
nationale qui s'est réuni et qui a
entendu monsieur thomasporte le bureau
après en avoir délibéré très longuement
a décidé de proposer à l'Assemblée
nationale de prononcer à son encontre la
censure avec exclusion temporaire sur le
fondement du cinquième alinéa de
l'article 70 du règlement de notre
assemblée qui sanctionne les
provocations envers l'assemblée je
rappelle qu'au terme de l'article 73
alinéa 3 de notre règlement la censure
avec exclusion temporaire emporte deux
droits la privation pendant deux mois de
la moitié de l'indemnité parlementaire
allouée aux députés elle entraîne
l'interdiction de prendre part aux
travaux de l'Assemblée et de reparaître
dans le palais de l'Assemblée jusqu'à
l'expiration du 15e jour de séance qui
suit celui ou la peine a été prononcée
en application de l'article 72 alinéa 5
la censure avec exclusion temporaire et
prononcée par l'assemblée par assis
élevé et sans débat sur proposition du
bureau je vais donc vous demander de
vous prononcer
je demande à ceux qui se prononcent en
faveur de la censure avec exclusion
temporaire contre Monsieur porte de se
lever
je vous remercie je demande à ceux qui
sont contre la censure de bien vouloir
se lever
je vous remercie
donc je constate qu'il y a une large
majorité de notre assemblée qui se
prononce pour la censure avec exclusion
temporaire de Monsieur Thomas porte
nous pouvons en prendre acte
nous lui demandons de bien vouloir
quitter l'ensemble de l'Assemblée
nationale
je souhaiterais avant de lever la séance
vous dire
que ce que nous voyons actuellement dans
nos débats
la façon malheureusement dont nous
échangeons avec nos investir avec nos
insultes avec du brouhaha
ne sont pas dignes de l'Assemblée
nationale dans laquelle nos sièges ont
j'invite l'ensemble des parlementaires
qui ont été élus par nos compatriotes
qui nous regardent de se montrer digne
et respectueux de leur fonction de cet
enceinte et de l'ensemble des Français
qui nous ont élus je vous remercie et je
suspends la séance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]